[Music]
for as long as we've told stories about
aliens we've told stories about alien
invasions tales of visitors from the
beyond coming to lay waste to our planet
after all one only has to look out into
the darkness of the night sky to worry
about what might lurk among the stars
but imagine the opposite scenario
imagine if humanity's first interaction
with alien life isn't them invading our
planet but us invading theirs what if in
a twist of cosmic fate the most
dangerous life form in the universe is
us
humanity lost a world-building project
and graphic novel series by artist
callum diggle imagines a future where
humans have merged with a godlike
artificial intelligence and are now the
most dangerous life forms in a galaxy
full of aliens it's an exciting twist on
the genre in a story that features some
particularly inventive speculative life
forms so for this entry into the archive
i'll break down the universe and
timeline of humanity lost explaining how
humans reach this point the aliens who
stand against their expansion and what
might come after
at the start of the 26th century
humanity has yet to give itself over to
the ai under the oversight of the united
earth government humans populate every
major celestial body in our solar system
on earth's moon giant lava tubes are
terraformed and become home to great
cities larger than any on earth yet as
humans seek out more and more distant
planets they soon encounter another
sentient species one which will set them
on a path towards a dark future
in the mid-26th century a distant human
probe discovers planet chiron a dry
world that has become hotter over the
past several million years on the
surface they find that in response to
the growing desert megaflora called
mammodae have arisen acting as natural
reservoirs holding on to the last of the
planet's water within these vast plant
structures human explorers find a
complex internal ecosystem that
constantly recycles water and in return
provides nourishment to the mammal day
outside the lush interior of the mammoth
day the united earth government
discovers in the desert more life in the
form of the living wave a horde of
scavengers chasing across a region
called the shifting sea eating
everything they encounter these
inventive aliens are actually inspired
by strand beasts real structures made by
artist theo janssen that are propelled
by the wind in a way which resembles
walking animals despite actually being
made out of wood and just looking at
videos of the strand beasts you can see
why they make such good alien designs
but the living wave isn't the only thing
the ue discovers even more significant
is the revelation that a species of
intelligent aliens also live here the
sixth limb chantari are the first
intelligent life humans make contact
with the chanthari are unhappy with the
presence of the united earth government
which begins to establish colonies and
mine the planet for resources which the
less technologically advanced chantari
are helpless to prevent to the chantari
humans are the alien invaders humanity's
treatment of the chantari awakens a
previously unknown alliance of alien
systems known as the conglomerate
swiftly decimating the human presence on
chiron in a stroke of dark cosmic
justice the conglomerate proves to be
far more powerful than the united earth
government realizing they are hopelessly
outmatched the uae activates a dangerous
newly constructed ai in their
desperation to win the war
and win the war it does but humanity as
we know it is lost transformed into
genetically altered avatars of the
machine's will encased in biomechanical
suits of armor troopers like these are
dropped on planets as the first wave of
the invasion looking more like insects
than humans today these drones are
little more than puppets of the great ai
and after the troopers come the great
krakens enormous living spacecrafts that
descend on an alien planet and bombard
it from above but the ever expanding
force of what was once humanity isn't
just destroying worlds it's reshaping
them to its will
late into the 26th century the empire
spreads across the galaxy like a
relentless tide transforming other
planets into biomechanical factories
known as womb worlds these worlds spew
out more augmented troops and ships to
continue the cyclical nature of the ai's
malignant expansion with this empire now
called the imperium moving across the
galaxy only the remaining aliens of the
conglomerate stand in the way
so what life forms make up the
conglomerate the founders of the
alliance are the seuss this space-faring
species originally hails from planet
solace a low-gravity world with a dense
atmosphere perfectly suited to moving
around in such a strange environment the
soos ruled the skies of their home world
thanks to a biological jet propulsion
system a bit like an aerial version of
an earth nautilus like all members of
the conglomerate the soos are an
advanced species
the second species to join the alliance
are the pect originating from an icy
moon orbiting a gas giant they have
evolved in geothermally heated oceans
trapped below the moon's icy outer shell
within these dark waters the peck
adapted bioluminescence that they used
to communicate with each other much like
many deep sea species on earth thanks to
specialized crafts that let them venture
beyond the ice this unlikely group has
become a vital member of the
conglomerate alliance
in terms of engineering the primary
manufacturers of conglomerate warships
are the brem henians evolving on a
crushing high gravity world called wim
rig bremhenians are as rigid and sturdy
as their technology originally living in
vast subterranean cities brimhinians are
almost like a group of intelligent moles
and while the high gravity of their
planet meant the brim hemians were never
able to reach space on their own with
the help of the conglomerate they're now
a major ally against the imperium
on the opposite end of the biological
spectrum the velosians are gelatinous
soft tentacled species that
paradoxically are some of the greatest
warriors in the alliance with a culture
of honor and tradition the velosians
historically resolved almost any dispute
through combat in particular by way of
the blade with three brains two of which
are dedicated entirely to a single arm
tentacle velocity and motor skills are
unparalleled this kind of decentralized
intelligence is similar to that of an
octopus a key line of the conglomerate
defense
but the conglomerate haven't been able
to keep every system safe the thick
coated ver a are a group of interstellar
refugees whose homeworld was destroyed
and now live under the protection of the
conglomerate originally adapted for the
frigid swamps of their home planet the
ver-a's pole-like toes allow them to
keep themselves above the water level of
the swamp and to hang from swamp trees
much like sloths do on earth now these
swamps are factories for imperium forces
and their numbers are few
as the imperium continues to spread the
conglomerate has had to make alliances
with ancient enemies the gourd are a
bizarre species that have long been seen
as impossible to ally with curiously the
gourd are technically not one species
but two the central plant-like core of a
gourd works as a hive for smaller
insect-like drones providing guidance
through complicated pings of information
that the drones are perfectly adapted to
understand serve and reply the flying
drones in turn act as the eyes and hands
of the central plant structure pinging
visual information back to the structure
and allowing the gourd to manipulate
objects around them a quite unusual
setup almost like a sentient beehive yet
through this symbiosis the gord have
developed their extremely advanced
civilization and now often wear
environmental suits such as this one
adapted for their unique anatomy indeed
the gourd are so unique that their
language and culture is practically
indecipherable to any other species of
the galaxy which unfortunately led to
several wars between them and the
conglomerate in the past but with all
the galaxy in jeopardy the gore joined
the alliance and become a powerful ally
in the fight against the imperium
but not all sentient species have joined
the conglomerate the tandraks are the
single most technologically advanced
species in the galaxy so advanced they
have little interest in the imperium
conglomerate conflict they live solely
within dyson swarms giant constellations
of satellites that orbit a sun absorbing
all its energy the tandrax strange
bodies are perfectly suited to the
zero-g environment of space with air
jets all over their body and large
webbed tentacles they use as air breaks
yet as advanced as they are with the
imperium continuing to expand they might
at last need to change their
isolationist ways
yet in this galaxy of aliens and
post-humans forgotten aboard a derelict
ship there is one final life form worth
mentioning a single human accidentally
trapped in stasis for hundreds of years
has recently awakened to find themselves
the last of their kind crash landing on
planet chiron the world where this whole
mess began the last human finds an
unlikely ally in a lone chantari the
first alien species humanity encountered
long ago now on the run from the
watchful ai it's possible this lone
human holds the key to saving the dream
of humanity
that's all i can give away in this video
the story of humanity lost is ongoing
but if you find the world building as
interesting as i do you can support
calum diggle on patreon to gain access
to the graphic novel for just a dollar
and fifty cents i've included a link to
it in the description and as always
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
entry please lend your support by liking
subscribing and hitting the notification
icon to stay up to date on all things
curious see you in the next video
you